t
d'entraînement pour l'escorte
policière du pape ou
l'installation de la scène
rassemblement de la visite,
dans la capitale albertaine,
on met la touche finale
aux préparatifs avant l'arFranç.
événements à grand déploiement
sont courants, la visite papale
demeure exceptionnelle",
souligne la police d'Edmonton.or
combien de visiteurs sont
attendus, mais au moins 63 000
personnes seront rassemblées
au stade du Commonwealth mardi
Ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'Edmonton reçoit le pape.
dans la capitale albertaine en
1984. La visite du pape François
sera toutefois beaucoup moins
de l'Église catholique vient
présenter ses excuses pour
le rôle de l'Église dans les
pensionn
NICOLE POIRIER, dir., festivals
et événements, Vilton
- Pour Edmonton, c'est
une visite qui est faiteation.
- Au-delà de la logistique,
la Ville concentre ses efforts
pour accompagner les nombreux
qui ravive de douloureuses
s. Des travailleurs
sociaux seront notamment
déployés un peu pa- La r- La r-,
c'est complètement différent!
Ça, c'est pas un "state visit",
c'est vraiment la chance pour
autochtone.
les communautés autochtonesqui ,
on ne se prépare pas seulement
à des f
Cette survivante de Maskwacis
sait que le passag
de l'Église sera douloureux.
La Confcatholiques du Canada ae
que l'organisation de la vis
a toujours été faite en
consultation avec les peuples
à leurs besoins.
Mgr RICHARD SMITH,
archevêque d'Edmonton
- C'était très important
d'entrer en dialogue avec
notre partenaire indigène p
savoir quelles sont les manières
de faire tout ce qui est
- Le pape lui-même l'a dit :
pénitentielle. La nature sombre
yage explique aussi
probablement pourquoi,
à la veille de socapitale alber,
les signes de la visite du pape
François sont plutôt discrets.
Radio-Canada, Edmonton.
- Le pape François va atterrire,
à l'aéroport international
Ce sera une arrivée hors du
commun. L'accès ort
sera bloqué de 14 h à 16 h.
Tous les passagers qui ontvrontt
obligatoirement se présenter
à l'embarquement avant
cette fermeture.
aéroport Jean-Lessage
torités notorités notorités nott
confirmé que même les gens
qui auraient un der au site.
- C'est tout un défi logistique
pour l'équipe de l'aéroport,
qui s'affaire à atténuer les
Et attention : le publicn'est .
- Le site aéroportuaire
n'est paL'accès va être réservés
qui ont un vol à
cette journée-là et il sera
complètement fermé pendantrira
et quittera l'aéroport.
- Et la circlation pourrait bien
être compliquée un peu partout
- On va essayer de faire ça
pour réouvrir le site.
n entendu,n entendu,n entendu,nr
une présence policière accrue
cette journée-làconvoi du pape
sera impressionnant.
DANIEL DANCAUSE
- Tout le convoi va être
Il va y avoir des drones,il va t
au travers de ça, il va y avoir
de la foule. On ne veut aucun
incident.
- L'arrêt de deux jours du pape
à Québec coûtera à l'Édadadadada
et aux contribuables environ
3 millions de dollars,
une somme grandement attribuable
- Dans ce cas-ci, c'est
ier parce ier parce ier parce it
longtemps qu'il n'est pas venu
au Québed même dans un contexte
un peu controversé.
- L'Agence des services
frontaliers du Canada prévoit
voudront entrer au pays. Tous ca
frontière doivent prévoir leurs
- On comprend les désagréements
que ca p
certaines personnes, d'arrivà le
à l'aéroport, mais c'est
vraiment la meilleure
des solutions pour s'assurer
- Pour ce qui est du départ
du pape François prévu en avant-
midi le 29 juillet, l'aéropoont
beaucoup moins importants.
Par contre, la sécurité
demeurera omniprésente, mais la
sera de très courte durée.
t,
Radio-Canada,
à l'aéroport de